[Musique]
je n'ai marc de sortir avec un gallon
moi je suis un gamin était sérieuse ces
convergences les mondes invisibles
[Musique]
moi j'en ai marre je suis venu voir from
bagdad
q si vous êtes en forme alors mis moi
cette à la dame
et pour moi une baguette pas trop cuit
je peux essayer de transformer maître
des arts martiaux
super ça alors même cheveux chez nous
je suis à la d'un prince de bagdad en
tentant moi chanson mal je suis venu au
un pro de bagdad ont dû siffler ou dit
enfin 43 minutes pour dégager mon palais
shakira waka waka et alors on embête les
petits
c'est lequel des deux mains selwa ec
raismes en attaque et après ils appuient
sa soeur là et moi mon bet dossier le
monde bête du monde